okay good you ready to go I'm ready
whenever you are here we go alright
ladies and gentlemen you know we back
welcome to your favorite podcast you
know the name sticking mic Josh
I always offer it to the guests what you
got right bubble written with Griffin on
a Monday afternoon me and my Eric me and
my dude hanging out down here on the
west side waiting to get home time I get
high on Monday nights in my backyard I
got wrong
I go hard here we go me and my man back
to you you can call me stay
accomplish let me take some that is like
some old school that's an old school
like that should be the beginning of a
TV show that credits rolling you walk in
waving to the people on the show your
neighbors coming out the door it was
nice you know but it's so funny like all
the comments that come on and they age
themselves with that kind of that rap
style right there yeah that's what it is
that's what that's a hundred percent
what it is you know like my son and I
like completely different rat I like
some I don't even call it rap with these
kids my days in comparison but you know
I played him ut'fo Roxanne Roxanne oh
but but that doesn't necessary stand up
but was entertaining I know what you
mean though but so I asked him it and I
old I played him so kool Moe Dee and
like cuz I was like what about this
stuff yeah and and then he was like man
I don't really like it and I was like
what what what is it you don't like he
was like this whole beat is like I know
it's just he didn't yeah it was before
rat was musical by the way before we
continue because I love this discussion
we're already having right now but
ladies and gentleman welcome to the
podcast they're very funny mr. Josh wolf
yeah all right so you're here yes I know
what you mean he feels like it's it's
almost like a joke like he feels like a
jokes coming you know you know what it
is because that's how it's used now yeah
like when you look back on things you
don't look back of it with fondness
necessarily even unless you're like from
that era not at all
like he didn't like to run the jewels at
all yeah he don't like you know he
wouldn't no no no none of it none of it
none but he loves me yeah that's not his
thing at all but he loves him some logic
right he loves logic he loves a little
dickie you he likes that style it was
funny is like rap right now is like it's
one of the it's it's an art form
we actually saw the birth of it yeah so
now we're seeing old you know what's
funny about some of the rappers like
kids today don't even know they don't
know ice-t as a rapper they think LL
Cool J is an actor and by the fat by the
way the fact that I've heard some people
say that nas isn't hip-hop I'm like what
are you saying
that's he that's how C that's a great
example nas is like he's on the Mount
Rushmore right there's kids that don't
like Tupac these kids that don't like
they think nas is old there's that you
know what jay-z's coming to his end you
know he's just transitioned into someone
that's like more of a mogul more like
he's found a way to stay relevant and
hip and he's with Beyonce in Arab
they're part of like sort of like a
social movement and like you know the
same with Diddy oh yeah yeah yeah he's
not a rapper at all what he never really
was but you know yeah he's almost like
Saudi so those are people that have
found a way to transition their their
their thing but like it seems like rap
is like a young man's game you know what
I mean
it's true you know so you know Ice Cube
has it at three ball right yeah and so
my son and I will watch it but he asked
me he goes how come he's out there
rapping and I was like well that's how
he started he was like what I'm like
yeah that's why he's out there rap yeah
we was like when he get a real rapper to
do it I'm like oh what actor out there
rapping before a game I'm like no he is
like one of the he started a style of
rap it was a hilarious part two is them
thinking that Ice Cube's a great actor
and that's why the transition he's a
mogul I had never thought about that
though man that we have seen the
beginning of an art form yeah and now
we're seeing like now so we're 50 years
in yeah you're however long and now
we're seeing like how you know how it's
these people have aged you can't stay in
it forever or right or you know and how
how are the different how the sounds of
change yeah how the like you know but I
always say like you know coolness
doesn't last long you know it's like
from 15 to say 27 right is your time to
be cool everything after that is you're
no longer cool if you're the 27 year old
that like you know some party with 18 to
20 year olds you instantly become like
you don't realize this but you're that
guy that probably shouldn't be there but
they're still kind of like well okay but
every it's just downhill from there and
your coolness doesn't it doesn't last
like we don't learn new dances no no and
what we think is cool
stays in our era exactly it's it's a
time capsule right do you know how long
it took me to really get just be okay
with wearing jeans that were just a
little tighter do you know what I mean
like because when I was growing up and
short when I was good those were high
waters and you were it that you were
made fun of God that knows funny now
like a guy of your frame you actually
you know what will fit better with you
girl jeans yeah if you go we'll just
don't go to get the girl they just they
fit better because they're designed to
like you know it's for a very hip it's
crazy yeah it's really bananas like and
now that the baggy things are coming
back yeah I'm like yeah baby cycles
right if I got those old 90 jeans so
this thing about like what's to do from
Harry Styles yeah I saw this article you
know he's like Harry Styles is bringing
back bell-bottoms
it's like he's bringing he's is he
bringing him back yeah this in Chris
Porter tried yeah you know he's not cool
enough I heard him say why he stopped
wearing those it's cuz he had to get
each pair custom-made cuz he couldn't
get him in oh you couldn't get ya cuz
they're like no dude nobody makes this
anymore oh and for probably a good
reason I will tell you this though I'm
not happy that they brought back the
high-waisted jeans for women yeah I
don't think those look good on anybody
yeah in any era it makes your vagina
look real long yeah that's not a
adjective you want for
vagina and then it accentuates that
belly area for everybody but men men and
women like it makes your ass look long
and it makes whatever is in front look
long yeah just depends on the frame like
that you know you'll be tall and thin
and maybe even get away with it that's
what my girlfriend's tolerance in and in
like when she goes to these fashion
shows she's a model you know she could
lose these fashion shows and they like
drop that in there I know you could have
stopped them because she knew like we
said she's model he's looking right at
everybody because she's a model yeah
yeah listen guys I'm also charming as
[ __ ] so [ __ ] you guys by the way because
women put much more of a premium on a
sense of humor than men do the things
that are attractive to women are not the
same things than men or attracted to
like sense of humor it ain't even in the
top ten no I just read an article ready
where they did eight they did a survey
and they found out four top three for
women uh-huh
was sense of humor in a man you know
what top three for man what a woman who
will laugh at his jokes hilarious but it
says so much about us what it says about
us is we we want to be the center of
attention
I still have a joke about this it's like
so women like you know it's like women
like sense of humor yep make a good
living yep you want to get taken care of
and don't be a child you know right
right make a good living right some
other the other ones are so practical
yeah let's have some men you ask man if
you just behind closed doors it's gonna
be like nice titties yeah what would
face that here's what I want that's like
this is if you were single right now I'd
be like look she does whatever I want in
the bedroom that's the thing
she's experimental
yeah if you don't like it you willing to
go okay is so different yeah try it try
it grown-up and one is made by just us
yeah I know I know but in what the thing
about us is we'll take two out of three
you know me there's a top but yeah this
and she doesn't pronounce salmon with an
L I'll go out with her yeah whatever go
for the girl in college you pronounced
salmon with an L all that means you were
really picky no man I just cuz she'd
like to make it for me I know what I
want you do that once you move over a
little bit more this way because of you
cuz you're like a laughs mover yeah man
but anyways I do you know you love
languages did you do the love language
test he's Spanish and French and Latin
oh god no you have a lot of languages
you like you know acts of service touch
physical touch you don't even know what
you're talking all honestly I have
because I've because I've done it you
know I did it with my girlfriend and I
have both done it and yeah me Jason it
is it's actually now the actual doing of
the test to me is even more important
than that the results because when
you're doing the test the questions they
ask you really say something about you
when you're when you're answering you
got to go do this but like Kristen's
some of the love languages things are
looking at KMC acts of service physical
touch words of affirmation quality time
receiving gifts okay these are like some
of the things and they're ranked by well
how you answer the question so mine are
that's the order of mine I like acts of
service you know
you like them to be able to do something
for you yeah like it's like pick me up
from the airport you know you know what
I've always said I like and it sounds
super super strange and my wife knows
this if I'm on the couch and I'm
watching a show or a game or whatever
right and you just bring me a sandwich
I'd ask for acts of service you if you
bring me a sandwich I didn't ask for man
I'm gonna check it out we're in I know
my girlfriend's the numbers are
different hers are physical touch is
first receiving gifts a second you know
it's like you you need to know this
about your partner ah I really want to
do that what's the what's you you send
me the link for that yeah see you later
but it's just it's just called the love
languages you know lovely but I'm
telling you that the test itself will be
like like first as it might be like
you're on the couch do you want her to
do this do this or do this and those
answers you really go down these are
actually very interesting or things and
you'll get the results you want but
anyway here's my point
I like acts of service my girlfriend
just arted picking me up from the
airport you know we used to fight about
this because like I like it a certain
way like I come in on United here's the
[ __ ] parking lot for 7:00 I want you
to be at the end of 7 you don't need to
park at the beginning of 7 because when
we come out the door we can go to the
car right here that was a whole thing
and at first it was just about like
she's very stubborn like tell me what to
do that kind of thing
yeah but now she does it she came to the
airport she had my favorite coffee
you know she's waiting there and she did
the cutest thing she was standing by the
guys that have the signs of signs and
she had her phone like Eric in and I
mean and I was like oh my heart
fluttered yeah but that dude that's the
difference between having a girlfriend
and being married for 20 years you know
but but she's not doing that yeah but
that's not the point though what I'm
saying is like it's just the act of
service because for her she likes
getting gifts right so that sounds bad
some people I think that but no if I get
her a $10 gift certificate from
Starbucks like hey I got this for you
the way she responds I go well that's a
real thing yeah if that's your love
language do you know what it is for my
wife and and she's asked she said that
to me before I should do it because what
I changed your marriage i I
we're definitely do that but I've always
when I go away
I've always gotten at least one thing
from my kids from the city I'm in now
for my youngest son he always wanted a
baseball hat
Sofer I mean through high school I'm not
kidding he probably had 150 hats just
hanging on his wall
right because it signified every city
I'd ever been at right that's good stuff
right just but little thing don't have
to be expensive but my wife said to me I
brought her home something and she
teared up and I was like what's a deal
yeah yeah she said it's nice to know
that you were thinking about me see what
I'm saying that's love language you
don't think like that though I know but
that's why you got to take this test yes
cuz because just not just for you to
take the test for her too for her cuz
cuz here's the thing though something
that we say don't value let's say you
don't value it but to know that they
value it means then you go oh cuz even
if it means nothing to you it's the
reason why I always say like like I was
telling young people like young people
especially young women like stop
worrying about a guy taking you to
dinner that ain't that [ __ ] ain't
special
cuz I'm I have to eat or I'll die so I'm
taking you someplace nice yeah but daddy
got money it don't matter
yeah but you ain't getting over on me
you know like there's this idea that
they like oh boy you know he took me
then I'm getting a free meal [ __ ] we
both getting me yeah yeah I'm coming
here anyway yeah call my boy I'd be like
yo Josh let's go eat see we can have a
good conversation about how dumb seems
like so so but when you know like I
would often say is like I remember a
long time ago when I was dating long
time ago I went on a date but but she
told me that she missed being from where
she was from and taking her grandma to
play bingo I shouldn't do that once a
week guess where I took her on the first
day it's stupid it was dumb
nobody's great man I know but what I'm
saying is it ain't actually it's that
act of like one listening and and like
you know if that means something to
someone so that's what I'm saying when
you find out it's a simple thing but
finding out the love languages it's just
so it's just one
cool to be like oh you really value this
yeah you know I gotta start that's a
great one like physical touch is one of
them yeah so like some people like some
people are kind of like maybe you don't
like that yeah but somebody else might
be like physical touch is their number
one so that means they all they want the
closeness they want you know what I mean
yeah so anyways you just you just you
know it's just how different men and
women are yeah and there are tools out
there to find out how we can like figure
out the Rosetta Stone that's a good one
that I'm definitely gonna take a look at
you know what I mean yeah there's some
things off because I know I'm thinking
about it Shh I should I wouldn't even
say she drops hints they're pretty solid
clues yeah it's like a message yeah but
but but you need to yeah I'm thinking
about it now dude and there's a bunch of
things that easy things that I could do
but the thing is just like here's a
thing though all right
I'm glad you said it like that cuz to me
it feels like because it's easy for you
you don't give it value that's exactly
what it is yeah so once you realize that
this eat and how great the equation now
is something that is so easy for you to
do means so much to the other person
then [ __ ] do it
and you know what it heads off at the
pass the problems you have in the future
exactly so like I had a girlfriend and I
broke my god we've been broken up for a
while you know like few months you know
but even though we were still seeing
each other
cause you know you you were so close to
somebody you don't just but then we got
back together and part of it was like me
going like okay what's my issues what
was I doing wrong in the relationship
you know like what was I you know and a
lot of it has to do with like different
thinking you know yeah like if I want
you to think a certain way and you're
not thinking that way and I'm getting
mad that you're not thinking that way
maybe it's like once I realize well this
person doesn't think that way so me
getting mad about it that's my issue -
that's a me problem I had a friend of
mine who I'm not gonna put our dirty on
laundry in the air but somebody we both
know
who i'm dear friends with we didn't talk
for two years and then because it was
some [ __ ] he was doing and then my
brother said to me he was like hey
what's going on with so-and-so I haven't
talked to him a couple years he said why
I told him and he said hey man not for
nothing I know that was shitty but let's
say you problem and I said why he said
that's who he is you can't get mad at
somebody for who they are you either
accept it or you don't and if you don't
that's cool that's up to you but if you
do then you can't keep getting mad at
him for who he is it's just recognizing
the problem that you are causing because
of this thing yes you know what I mean
yes like you know you have you're not
gonna you're not gonna change somebody
outright so you can either work amongst
the confines of how they live their life
and be okay with that
or not yes ma'am my mom used to say that
that you have acceptable negatives and
unacceptable negatives so like an
acceptable negative would be snoring yes
okay being late too big you know see not
for me like I can't stay with people
like you know like they they don't they
don't they don't they're not consider it
I can't stand being inconsiderate is an
unacceptable negative for me but but
those are the kind of things I'm saying
but what list you go like no no because
sometimes it's like you know what people
just don't care about your time mm-hmm
they're just like whatever like I can't
stand with somebody pick you up from the
airport okay and they go like what can
you call me when you land
I'll and the airline's set that up yeah
they gotta set up
[Applause]
yeah you want me to pick you up from the
airport cuz guess what I mean if I'm at
baggage claim
I'm sending in a like hey what's up Josh
yeah you ready he had cars over here
with your bags okay we're ready to go
but I mean yeah that's how I do it
I'm not circling the [ __ ] Airport
waiting for you you know you know and
you're like outside like where are you
I'm not down my hey man okay I'm coming
now no I know how [ __ ] up it is to
travel I know how hard it is I know how
tired you are when you get off a plane
I'm gonna be there okay so I can't steal
you know when you land give me a coke no
but you know what I track your flight on
my phone
it's pretty easy it's easy yeah yeah I
know oh it says it's coming in 20
minutes early yeah you don't gotta worry
yeah you know you're gonna walk out be
like oh [ __ ] you're here yeah yeah
because you know I got a text alert I
had a guy from a club show up late night
my plane landed early late night so now
instead of a 1 a.m. pickup I'm in at
12:30
Ryan Airport is empty and you know we're
flying redeye and I got pressed the next
morning and he pulled up and he's like
how long you been here I said I've been
here for like cuz then he gave 15
minutes the end for me to get my bag so
I waited 45 right right right and I said
to my god didn't you track my flight
yeah on the phone anyway said to me can
you do that and I was like yeah man you
could definitely do that
I hate even more those kind of people
that don't because they're acting like
well you know I don't want to be
inconvenienced yeah you know this is
part of the deal
well it's your job it's your [ __ ] job
yeah that's your job it's your job as
did you get to the airport bro you know
what and I know some people get on me
specifically sometimes about you're
picky about your travel I spent half my
life on planes and in hotels so it's
like having a second home yeah so I'm as
picky with my travel as I am about my
actual house right because I spend equal
amount of time in both places so I'm not
crazy but like you know if you say
12:30 12:30 I'm some hotels need to
change their name
you know like just call it in and Suites
yeah don't
put words on it that you can't you live
up to
yeah like the word quality put the worst
so so so I'm at this hotel and it's like
it's 14 miles away from the club I know
I'm out on that this is I know
something's up already okay and I
should've saw this in advance and that's
on me yeah I'm going to my people now
like yo don't just say don't just sign
off let's see what's going on here the
guy comes next to my well yeah what's
going on here I'm not a truck stop like
what's happening yeah there's nothing
around dude look at me this isn't just
nothing here there's a church in the
parking lot and there's nothing around
oh how am I gonna eat
where we gonna go what kind of mood
you're gonna have me in you know he's
like well the other hotel was sold out
it's usually right by the club okay okay
right my agent he goes they got rooms
you know so I moved and I thought I was
being a diva now I did until I got to
the new hotel and I physically felt
better
no dude I'm with you although I was like
oh I'm in a better mood yes Starbucks
there's like there's restaurants and I
was like oh now I'm ready for this you
know and I was like oh this is so
important so I'm making a more effort to
be like my it is I always get in advance
what the hotel is where it is and then I
usually book my own but the big thing
you know what it does for me honestly
you know why it sets me in a sour mood
because right away I'm like oh this is
what you think of me that's what we
think but it's just no no no but I know
that's not yeah but but what it is is
listen if you and I get in business
together
yeah and I say to you hey man come on
out I'm gonna put you up at a hotel and
one hotel is a hundred dollars a night
and it's 14 miles away and the other
ones $20 more so three nights yeah it's
$60 yeah that you're getting into
business with me and you're gonna [ __ ]
up our business relationship over $60 it
tells me a lot well what it is is like
no us yeah I know I see why you take it
to a more personal level but to me I
look at it as like I see what they
prioritize more and it's just like it's
just money
and that's it but that's what
I think we're saying the same thing yeah
we are I think we're saying it so it's
still like an approach where it's like
you know you the person you could just
say to them like yo you know was this
worth it was this what's happening worth
that and they might even realize like I
guess it's not you know cuz I don't
Kazemi Nev $60.00 I don't I don't care
if it's $100 I'm alright night
know at some point you go this is has to
be a priority comforted me yeah comfort
is a party I mean people don't realize
they think like oh it's like know people
that don't travel a lot don't understand
like how much yeah what's around the
hotel is important I mean it's one
surrounded although it's super important
to me because I don't rent a car yeah
you ready for this someone I was in I
was doing a funny bone the the one in
Kentucky right below Cincinnati they
used to call it the Cincinnati funny yes
yes yes yes yes you know that one yes by
the way I saw two fights out in front of
that club that ended up on worldstar
that were amazing but I'm in a hotel
right and this is just this wasn't what
tells me a lot so I go into the hotel
and you know what I always do when I
walk into a hotel by the way before I
walk into the room I will take a book
and I will throw it into the room and
let it land uh-huh if there are critters
on the rugs they feel vibrations they
jump right on the book and you can hear
it really they feel vibrations they
can't hear or smell but they feel that's
how they feel your feet and they jump to
your ankles so I'll throw it in there
and make sure it's white cover and if I
see anything land on it I'm not walking
in so I'm in this hotel and I wait just
a second and usually if there's Eddie
you might hear it or uh-huh dude this
was the detective did and I looked and
there was probably about eight or ten
little so they're like little fleas or
what I don't know so I go downstairs to
the front desk and I say hey there's
bugs in my room and the woman behind the
desk goes oh are you in 3:17 so you know
this bugs at 3:17 what she was yeah we
thought we got rid of those
and I go let me see your manager manager
comes out and I go hey there are bugs in
room 317 that you knew about and the
managers you could see the looks right
at the front desk
they go to my office and we'll talk to
you when I'm done with this but he
turned to you but they said can we put
you in another room I said no and I
called the club and I said hey this is
the deal I'm moving hotels and the club
even said yeah we thought they'd cleared
that up and I was like yo what are we do
the levels of like where they just don't
really care they don't care they just
don't they don't care and so so I saw so
that they put you in a position where
you have to care yes and then you come
across like you're the diva crazy person
yes I can't stand that you have put me
in a position where I have to now go off
yeah here's the thing here's all I want
from a hotel room tell you truth from
hotel I would like you to be close to
stuff that I can get out and walk around
to number one on the list of the low
hotel love languages I gotta be able to
get out I got to if York we're comics
and you asked me about a club if you
said to me like hey Eric how's that club
the first thing I would say when you ask
me that I'd be like yeah the club's cool
right but I'd be like man the hotel that
that's what we start talking about
because we're all we're gonna have fun
at clubs we're gonna have shitty ones
we're gonna have fun because we do
stand-up we'd like to instead yeah but
the hotel is what make or where the
hotel is makes or breaks like I'm going
to Austin in December they there in
North Austin so they're always they put
you up in North Austin and I'm always
like no I'm staying downtown right I
know what the deal is but we've worked
that out long before because I would
rather be able to get out and walk
around yeah then to be right next to the
club it's specially where that club is
yeah yeah so I want to get out and walk
around man but I'll tell you so far is I
want close to something yes I would like
there to be food in the hotel
word right that's not crazy I would like
there to be food in the hotel and my
only other record this is it Jim Costa
things for the hotel the top of my list
Jim those are the three things that's it
because if you have those three things
I'm gonna trust that your mattress is
okay yeah do you know what I mean dude
that's just okay the dent in the middle
of the mattress you know when it slopes
down into the middle is a rough one for
me yeah well you just roll into this
hole let me ask you something about your
stand-up man I mean you started stand-up
went away and came back right yeah yeah
what made you go away and what made you
come back um well the going away part
was easy because like I didn't know what
I was doing and it was like there was no
like plan there was no like not
understanding that this how it works cuz
I'm from LA I was born and raised in LA
so I'm in LA so you're in LA let's say
like right now you wanted to start doing
comedy and you went down to the comedy
store I'm right now imagine how daunting
yeah and how like just overwhelming it
is to be like just to sit there and be
like how do you get on that stage yeah
right and not knowing like what I know
that it takes to get on the comedy star
stage I mean I don't even know what I
would tell my younger self I don't know
how I would like you know be like so
imagine like not knowing anything like
that I didn't know how to do anything
and then it was like I didn't know my
point of view I you know it was hard and
it was like you know then you would go
to these places to these shitty open
mics having to pay money to perform or I
didn't have it I didn't I didn't love it
I wasn't like what I thought I really
wanted to do because I didn't do the
things that was necessary to make it
happen and so it wasn't till I was older
that I was like oh I have to cultivate
relationships I have to you know prove
myself I have to like be undeniable I
have to like you know keep writing I had
this so once I saw the litany of things
that I needed to do to become a
a decent stand-up comedian was like that
was like I didn't I didn't understand
that and can organize it in my head
until I was older you know how many
years you step away for like Mike eight
yes yeah because I do remember I feel
like I met you early on yes but you know
I knew a lot of you know it's like it's
funny cuz like when I started I I
remember going to like open mics I saw
Jim Gaffigan and open minds yeah Amy
Kennedy and I saw these people that I
was like oh you know I did you know you
know you you're all so young and
arrogant you know so you're going to
like an open mic and you see the same
people right you're like these same
unfunny [ __ ] are here you don't I mean
and then doing the same [ __ ] you
know
and I'm like wow you know I'm funnier
than these people like I should already
be you know so you had those dumb
thoughts in your head at the time you
know I will tell you over the last four
years like your comedy has changed
exponentially for the better you really
fell into a groove I'm trying
where but but now when I watch you on
stage I'm like oh that's him yeah yes I
thought you know what it's funny you say
that I feel I feel like I feel like the
more the things like I know now that
[ __ ] happened to me and I'll go right to
this day yeah well you to me four years
ago you were still doing bits and right
now you're talking to us yeah but it's
still but still but I'm still using the
yes you know still it feels more rules
of like you know without a doubt but
there feels like a less performance
based yeah and more just like oh this
dude is really him super comfortable on
stage still a 70/30 but you know I know
what you mean though I appreciate that
thank you very much you know that's how
you take compliments you just go thank
you you know what I mean but other like
comics not usually good at compliments
yeah yeah not used to those
no I appreciate it and it's just like
you know that's just you know that's
just where we're at because like you
know but you know I guess a lot of that
has to do with just like not worrying
about also that you know not worrying
about like trying to to please everybody
or make everyone laugh yes it's just not
gonna happen like that you're always
gonna have like issues like I have an
issue too too too you know like the last
episode I had Andrew Santino on you know
and I was telling him a story about how
I went to the Apple store you know and
you know I waited a bestow it takes
forever and then like two people come
over in you know I'm here to help you
I'm just guy's translator so immediately
I have an attitude cuz I'm thinking to
myself they're hiring people that don't
speak English
ya know the guy was deaf so technically
I thought he was asking it for
translator because I thought he thought
you spoke funny you look foreign so
we're you know we're doing the comics
and going in about it so I could just
message from this kid who's like this
was ignorant my mom was deaf and we were
poor cuz deaf people don't have enough
you know opportunities by the way the
way we were talking about it was like I
was like I just need to like you should
tell me yeah
you should let me know hey you know what
this person's coming over you know it's
gonna take three times as long dude my
wife three times as long yes cuz cuz it
goes like this it goes I gotta tell you
yeah you got to tell them they gotta
tell you you tell me this is gonna take
longer yeah so you gotta let people know
hey you got extra time because we got
Helen Keller in the back no by the way
what the ayah says to me so source I say
sorry you feel that way you know good
luck with the rest of your life because
I just point them like whatever now you
say you should apologize you know as I
never know you know that you don't
understand website so then he says this
and this is the funny part okay the guy
the kid goes well what if I wanted to be
informed that the person is
back not the same thing not the same
thing at all it's not gonna slow down
your day but let me tell you right well
unless you have to post off yeah and it
takes a little while for her to tape
with those nails you know [ __ ] but
anyway here's the thing that's racist
about it so this guy assumed that the
person that was deaf wasn't black this
is going like you know they're gonna
hire someone deaf but we're not going to
negative thing is people don't think now
they just open their dumb [ __ ] mouth
without like taking the thought of being
like like how [ __ ] is stupid to equate
being black and being deaf and also just
hearing us talk about it and assuming
that we're saying all deaf people
shouldn't work nope
being deaf is a is a debilitating
disability yeah and it is probably hard
for you to get certain jobs yeah but you
know what you don't you shouldn't have
certain jobs like you know what I mean
but you're not answering phones at the
call center [ __ ] because you
can't hear ya I say that all the time
when my wife gets mad at me because when
I hang up the phone I'm like that person
was in customer service and I couldn't
understand a [ __ ] word they said that
what that's important it's customer
service you're serving me I'm spot I
don't understand why that my wife
invited one time we are having somebody
come over and fix our computer in your
hundred percent right you gotta let
somebody know right just let us know
I open the door [ __ ] or dwarf whatever
harm is whatever the term is little [ __ ]
hey little fella yeah and I looked down
and I wasn't you got to just let me know
so I didn't have the reaction which I
did which I had which was
oh okay you know what I mean like I was
bro that's the exact reaction I had when
the guy comes over he goes this guy's
deaf I went take longer I'm gonna have
to like okay you know okay
all right well this was a job it to fix
a computer
okay that's fine but but visually just
say oh and by the way little persons
coming over
don't you know what don't say anything
when you open the door I'm actually
gonna disagree with you now you gotta
let me know I not for that I I disagree
with you I disagree with you on that I
would say I would say let me know if it
was someone that didn't have arms but
but and they had to take their feet off
feet in there be amazed you'd be like oh
but I disagree with you on our honor
thing that like nothing's being hindered
by this person being hurt or except
right nothing cuz they still got their
little fingers with that it's also I
disagree with you on that point I will
tell you this I only said it because I
didn't want to make him feel
uncomfortable when I opened the door he
had a reaction he didn't need to get
right and the reaction was oh okay do
you know that do you not I mean like the
way to do that is it be like such as
such as coming over here as a picture
yes you want like you know you know ooh
BRR you get the person's face the name
yeah but but again though because I
think that that's that example is
different from my example without
because the deaf person now is gonna
take three times as long yeah but Eric
for me it's more like I feel like I made
him feel uncomfortable because of the
reaction I had do you know what I mean
but at this point what are you gonna be
like you're gonna be like you know he's
the dwarf so what are you gonna be
working yourself up before you open the
door
I'm gonna open the door on my knees come
here little fella so I don't know if
that would have made a difference would
have because I would not have looked up
and then down
I would there was a couple things where
I just I felt bad the way I reacted to
him yeah by the way he did a great job
he was of course he did no muss no fuss
by the way the Deaf dude was dope yeah
and I told him to I was like I'm gonna
talk about you on stage and he was like
you know oh you loved he was like what
can I see he was like what can I see you
and I was like well I'm on YouTube but I
don't know and he said I said see
[ __ ] here so it's like so I mean
you know it's just like well it's just
we live in like oh this weird like you
know he's weird [ __ ] ties it but
again that's the thing about what I'm
talking about with my comedy it's just
thinking back to it is that like you
don't know how a conversation we're
having right now is gonna affect people
out there and and it's like my thing is
like sometimes I feel like you know we
live at a time that everyone's
accessible so this guy had access to me
yeah I mean so this guy he had it's
personal to him he grew up with his mom
being deaf and and and and wasn't she
should have tried to apply to Apple
store obviously you know you can get a
job but but what I'm saying it's like so
that was personal to him so all he heard
was those beats those points he just
heard deaf but that's how comics did
exactly people take exactly they
personalize everything yeah so my thing
is you're either laugh at everybody or
nobody you can't pick and choose so that
same guy may laugh at an Asian joke or
fart joke why but deaf is personal to
him you can't personalize everything and
just say that's not okay to joke about
but all the because I'm sure you guys
touched on another subject exactly that
he didn't write a new about fine so you
look you're going like this yeah can't
you can't do that you know and also you
know it's so interesting how people
people now they they think a hundred
percent he's with me he's with me he's
with me one joke one thing you say and
you've gone from a hundred percent in
the camp to a hundred percent out right
that's what the guy said I looked up to
you and like now you dis ya you know
what
even if I don't I stand by what I was
talking about yeah but let's say even if
I did say something ignorant so I can't
have one and by the way nobody is a
hundred percent good yeah you understand
and if you agree with everybody a
hundred percent that's called a cult but
of course right let me give you an
example of something else dislike and
I'll I appreciate how and I don't even
know this girl who I'm about to talk
about right now and so I remember the
Santa Barbara the guy that kid at Santa
Barbara
he shot up the school yeah he the kid he
was being rejected by women yeah you
know I mean so I I had jokes about it
too just to point out like how it's
about mental health like we got a deuce
you know because I was like listen I you
know this is gonna be hard for you guys
to believe but I too have been rejected
by what you know yeah I've never thought
I need to kill these [ __ ] you know
but anyway I talked about it in a way
I'm being as thoughtful as I possibly
can be you know what I mean this is one
of those issues where you go do you talk
about this or do you not talk about it
but anyway I was at the Laugh Factory
and like one of the waitresses came up
to me after I got off stage and this
waitress was like oh my god you gotta
talk about that you know there was a
girl that she's crying in the bathroom
because she was actually at the school
okay
now I hear that and I go I I can't worry
about that no but here's what I
appreciate the chick went to the
bathroom yep and cried yeah cuz that
says a lot about her cuz to me she
probably I'm just assuming but like her
thought process could have been people
are enjoying this I know he doesn't he
he doesn't know that I was there so let
me not ruin this whole [ __ ] yeah acting
up yeah and removing myself because this
is a me problem yeah didn't come up to
me afterward but sometimes I've seen in
a different situation I saw like Neal
Brennan one time was talking about
something like this and a dude was in a
crowd like like it was like mag he's
like you know I knew those people or
whatever his thing was and I was like in
that instance that [ __ ] became
inappropriate yeah yeah so that's what
I'm saying about this situation is like
you know but didn't begin this guy came
to me personally I'm the one making it
public I'm talking about it like this
cuz I'm just trying to talk about it to
point out that like you know if
you don't understand the subtlety and
nuance of what someone's talking about
I don't assume I talked about this with
Andrew like when you have when you look
up a word in the dictionary there will
be two or three meanings yeah
you can't just deny all the other
meanings just cuz you think it means
this you know and that's what people do
so when I was coming up at first doing
stand-up it was like hard to decipher
like what you know like what's my plate
because I know my point of view I have a
very distinct point of view about things
what what do you feel like your point of
view is well I like it's hard to
articulate yeah I know what I mean but I
just I know I have a certain you did
looking at that you did you know you you
you also talked about things you come
from an angle that I do when I hear you
talk about things I'm like oh I know I
would have never thought of and the
things about it she was like I have this
whole thing about this dis handicapped
dude that was delivering my groceries
you know what I mean
yeah they drove me bananas anyway after
I what when I finished doing the set one
time this woman comes up to me and she
says she goes how man listen I work with
disabled people and I just really want
to thank you for talking about that in a
thoughtful way yeah you know because
it's not like cuz that's it to me that's
important to like that's me covering
myself so I'm gonna talk about it and
I'm hitting points I'm making fun we
were laughing it is jokes there's gonna
be some meanness in some areas there's
gonna be some like selfishness in other
areas but look what all things human
dude that's a that's a gamut of human
emotions and thoughts but overall though
if a person could come to me and go I
understand where you're coming from
yeah that's all I want but but what
people do like this kid is he only added
his yes point of view yes just him you
know just him and no one else matters by
the way you should be actively looking
for and listening to and watching people
who you disagree with for sure you
should actively I'm gonna tell you I do
it multiple times during the week and
I'm like I'm not gonna lie to you
all times during every week I'm like oh
that's not a terrible point I had never
thought of that from that angle you know
this is why I watch Fox News me too
and CNN me too you know I often go but
you know they it's like we live in two
different countries who'd they they feel
like a couple that needs marriage
counseling
yes but that's what American that's what
that's what's happening in America right
they be so different row because they
are because they're not reporting the
news oh I watch neither one of neither i
watch your eyes enn and then you know
what I would I want to see news I go to
BBC because when the BBC does news about
America
to me it's non-emotional news yeah but
sometimes though I can't stand that
looking down their nose at us like
they'd like their [ __ ] doesn't stink or
they get some problems over there yeah
this is why I don't like like oh I'm not
listen I appreciate what they do but I'm
not necessarily a fan of like Trevor
Noah
and the other guy the British guy on the
other show Oh HBO John Oliver John
Oliver it's because here's some smug
foreigners [ __ ] on our country using
our platform you know he's a cool dude
you know Oliver really makes me laugh
man I know he's funny but at the same
time I'm like get your smug face out of
here go fix breakfast [ __ ] yeah like
they're like the evil American and me
feels like that but you know it just is
what it is man so it's like that's why
I'm saying like I agree with you is like
but see we're you know not everybody
critical things not everybody know not
everybody people abandon common sense no
you know now your day-to-day is rooted
in emotion now yeah you yeah because
again they're not reporting the news
they're putting slants or emotion onto
the news so that's how you're receiving
it right they know who they're talking
to they're talking to like oh yeah
they're talking to this this person
who's gonna hate it when Don Lemon and
and Anderson Cooper when I can see their
disdain on their faces yeah yo tell me
the [ __ ] news Rachel Maddow
you know tell me the news say Fox are me
the news
I want the Newsweek and I want if I want
those aren't news people but I listen to
talk radio if I want that know what I
mean this is the thing here's the
problem I see I'm so glad you brought
those people people up in particular
those aren't journalists anymore they're
right they're not news people anymore
yeah you know but they're so they're
opinion people right yes and they and
they and they gather their opinions by
being like on the outskirts of like news
reporting but the problem with it is is
that they have they're presenting it the
same way the news and fox news are
supposed to be news sean hannity is not
a news guy he is basically the National
Enquirer yeah and he said a couple times
I don't I'm not a news show and he's not
a new show but he puts the suit on and
he's at the nest like the news is that
the desk he's lined and it doesn't even
matter that he's right wing because
Rachel Maddow same [ __ ] they're the
exact source yes with the exact same
haircut yeah they just have their own
slants but the way they're doing it is
the exact same way so let's like it's
hard to like fine like work and you [ __ ]
so so it's like that's what I'm saying
so as a person that's like why I'd like
to see both sides you know you know by
the way and I don't like this kid let me
reach out to this kid again I have no
problem with this guy it being personal
to him yeah you know I have no problem
with it being personal to him I wish it
was just presented in a way like I I
have a hard time hearing jokes about
deaf people because my mom was deaf it
sounds different from like you'd say my
opinion about the work taking three
times as long and this is something I'm
paying for and how I'm talking about it
is like oh that's ignorant by the way
except here's what I'd the one caveat I
would put on that I bet you he and his
family have a lot of great deaf joke
moments oh my god right so many so why
can't you take as long because for me
jokes are all about intent dude you're
not a hateful harmful first my intent
you're not out there saying deaf people
should never work and [ __ ] deaf people
you getting worth oh goodness put them
in camps
right this is not it you're saying you
went to a store this was your experience
yes period you don't have a run on deaf
people for no reason or no reason okay
okay this this whole reason why I'm
bringing it up is because this should
happen to me and it gave me something
yes they see to me that's the difference
between good comics and people who are
doing racist or insensitive or bigoted
[ __ ] but here's the thing though by the
way yeah there's all we text you're
right to do that but I'm saying that
they're still like sometimes you're
waiting in those waters yeah it's hard
to stay and stay away from some of those
waters because it just it's always gonna
be it's always gonna be received just
sort of play couched in your experience
it's it's not you're not getting up
there listing off these people who have
been disadvantaged in some way and just
taking shots exactly just randomly
that's not it yeah what's this oh thank
you it's your - it wasn't random I used
to do a joke about this dude who was
handicapped who was an [ __ ] and it
was hard for me to be an [ __ ] back to
him cuz he was handicapped mommy but he
was such an icky I was in line at a
grocery store in his wheelchair hit my
feet and I was like all right I'm not
gonna and I moved up a little bit any
food I hit my feet against and I'm like
I just turn around go ahead man yeah
just so you know your wheelchairs
hitting my feet and he goes I know and I
was like no okay so you know I mean like
yes you're handicapped and I'm sorry
you're handicapped but you're also an
[ __ ] so that goes to the top of the
list I remember like I remember there
was this like when I first started doing
comedy dude and there was this female
comic in a wheelchair you know or she
was either in a wheelchair or she was
the sister of somebody you know but
anyway she's heckling me yeah the show
you know and I said to her is that how
you got in the will
[Laughter]
were you running your mouth yes somebody
in a wheelchair I take two I take the
stance of like if you come to the show
you're coming and you want to be a part
of everything yeah then I'm gonna treat
you like I treat everybody else you
don't get any special treatment
you know what it's funny when I talk
about this deaf thing on stage cuz
that's what I do I talk about I'm
talking about it on stage yeah it's like
when I say this the phrase when I go
when I say other than the translator
people immediately everyone gets an
attitude it's so funny how everybody's
like oh I can't believe that like as if
the person not speaking English it lets
them be okay with having an attitude but
then when I hit him with the light will
he's deaf
then everybody goes yeah but I'm like yo
it's actually the same thing yeah yeah
but no like don't no don't don't don't
don't let this person have anything
extra to for it no no this is about
customer service that's it's not anti
deaf it's not anti-immigrant your job is
customer service I am the customer yeah
what's the best way for you to serve me
what's the most optimal way for this to
its right as well is that we speak the
same language yeah just I understand you
you understand me or or we have a easy
communication like we don't need a third
party that's not anti you it's not anti
them either it's basically this is the
job this is the you wouldn't like if
somebody was like hey man I got a
fireman coming over he's in a wheelchair
you big mmm exactly I don't have
anything can you know what you're gonna
get me in those I have a joke just about
this I have a job right now is because
that's an example where it now becomes
personal to them yeah when you put
somebody in that situation like you know
now they're gonna be like so I'm like
yes so which one do you want yeah you
wanna you want to dude standing up to
come save you from the fire yeah how do
you want this guy like now you're gonna
be like oh by the way and then they say
things like don't be ridiculous
cuz I want to talk about some other
things I good yeah cuz I cuz I have you
want I knew you I know you're this way
and I just thought I just thought I
would like you to finish off we're
talking about some like current topics
that I want to get your thoughts about
salutely so you know Joe Rogan was
talking about this - he's big on this
right now I don't know if you smoke weed
he's my line you said your weed smoker
good I'm not a weed smoker yeah but I
have recently started doing like you
know three to one four to one ratio and
yeah one yeah they pens I haven't done
it meat recently because I was a little
worried about how the vaping [ __ ] was in
the news I was like is that really bad
for you you know so I haven't and I was
traveling so I didn't good to go to my
favorite weed store but I found it very
like off-putting that Biden just to
publicly be like I want to be President
and to have this stance against
marijuana in a country where alcohol is
legal like I have such a problem with
that because I have personal experience
with an alcoholic and let me tell you
something I wish that [ __ ] was
addicted to weed dude it's not even
close if you just look medically at what
the two drugs do to your body and
long-term problems and you know your
brain everybody's brain I believe has a
THC receptor which means your body was
was born to receive it it to receive it
and it's all about also moderation yeah
like I always say this I don't think
weed makes you lazy but lazy people
shouldn't smoke weed yeah yeah like it's
not for everyone and anything in
moderation and like it's not you know
it's not him but what I'm saying is this
even if because obviously smoking no
weed and drinking no alcohol is probably
the better choice yes but what I'm
saying is that's not criminalize one I
talked about this on stage basically
because you know nobody's ever gotten
drunk and getting high and beat their
wife like that's not know people aren't
getting high and getting in fights too
often I know but there are people that
beat their wife that also get hot yes
but but like violence is associated way
more you know I went to that Lowell
Farms weed cafe here in LA you know
there's a place where you can go smoke
weed in LA
to restaurant oh that's great I'm LaBrea
and let me tell you I don't like the
burning by the way but go ahead the
difference between being in a bar with
booze in a bar with weed here's a couple
of things there was no screaming you
could hear the music you could talk to
each other and I'll tell you something
else fascinating you look around
nobody's on their phones nobody's taking
selfies people are smoking weed eating
food and enjoying conversation it is I
took Sickler there the other night with
Justin Martindale and jessimae Peluso we
just sat around man and laughed but you
know you have for comics around people
here let's take a picture let's pose
there wasn't ah say and I looked around
at other tables - okay but by push back
on that yes I've been to shows that like
you know I ever done a show like a weed
show oh yeah it's not a good show you
better get up early in the same way it's
like it's not like it's like the fun
that people have while they're drinking
and watching comedy is not the same fun
that's I don't know would be the same
sure you know I don't know if we could
like to to joint minimum I don't know if
we could start doing that no but I don't
know if it but but I just feel like I
don't think it's somebody and this is
the reason why the 2-meter liberal side
I'm a self-hating liberal cuz I just
can't stand like what the Democrats are
how they're going about a lot of things
me too we're not gonna get into politics
but I'm just saying to have that stance
who's that for like who's that for like
who's clamoring for like we just still
say like you know is it just it just
feels like it feels so old do you want
to give our money the Uniting United
States do you want to give that to
people who are farmers here in the
United States or do you want to give
that money to people in Mexico who grow
it illegally and bring it across the
border if you made it legal in this
country they wouldn't bring it across
the border there'd be no sales do you
know to say it I know if if like we
should be growing opium I'm set well
that seems it's like a slippery slope no
but I'm talking about opium as what sin
isn't opium what sin like tylenol and no
vicodin but whatever that whatever we
ought were not allowed to grow
is in a lot of the drugs that himself
yeah scroll - a year well here's the
thing
weed could also repeat his non-addictive
so I don't agree I don't think that's
true it's mentally addictive it's not
physically because it's addictive it's
different right so if I'm taking xanax
and I decided not to take xanax and I
and I've been taking it I could die the
withdrawal means I could die alcohol
withdrawal I could die so we'd addiction
right so there's a little bit of a
difference you can just stop we you can
stop honestly I just and I smoke every
day or I smoke every day and I've also
stopped for three months yeah I was
liking how that you know I was like I
was like I was like it was a nice
feeling man I'll take Friday my sad
Friday and Saturday late shows I take an
edible before I go onstage because and
then I'll tell stories that I'm stuck on
got it that my sober brain has not
allowed me to go down certain paths and
it opens up those stories into like you
know I I like to tell stories especially
on the repetitions yeah whatever I don't
have that problem those looks it's the
baby maybe maybe I should try it it's
not even in a vicious dude it's like or
that door was shut I had no idea that
door was a door it has changed my it has
changed my stage Who am I huh
I'm inmate as long as you can do but
here's the thing though is like can that
be replicated without that yes
okay well that's what's important yes
because there are people that I find
that like it's like it says it's like
those drunk comics now those comments
say they have to have to be they have to
be
a little drunk to do comedy yeah yeah
get out of my face
so it's like then it becomes like can
you can you duplicate that can you mimic
it because we're performers were actors
you know like like I'm not always as as
set as I feel like I am on stage but
it's part of the performance so I'm
saying this again so it's almost like
you know that's your PD well you know it
has taught me a lot of things you know
but the most important thing it taught
me about stand-up oh yeah yeah yeah for
sure because there was a minute there
you're manic pace on stage something not
anymore
yeah I think I said that to you yeah if
you would just take your time yeah
you're not anymore I started telling
these stories when I was high and it
just slowed me down I'm like this
story's working so much better they're
laughing the places you didn't think
they were gonna laugh there they're
getting different points and I'm letting
them take in the story it's not like an
event where they like what the [ __ ] is
happening yeah it's really letting them
I'm sitting down more I'm standing in
front of the mic without taking it out
but all that has come from experimenting
a lot of it when I've been high and it's
changed my my storytelling it's first
for the better for so much so much
better it's been amazing so then so then
you know to finish that topic it's like
so it's like you know do you think that
these politicians should be taking this
dance like do you think Biden running
for president should be taking this like
like this such a hard stance and and
like I said to you before who's it for
it's for the people he's trying to pull
over the moderate Republicans
it's those votes that Trump got that
he's trying to get back do you know what
I mean Wisconsin all those areas where
they still maybe a little on weed that
it's for those people I wish that there
would be someone that can explain like
clearly why it's like why are we okay
with alcohol and not money man its money
so if I okay weed it vicodin xanax all
these other things that Big Pharma has
are gonna take a hit so if I'm Big
Pharma I don't want legal weed cuz I
still why why so why why well because I
want you hooked on my drugs
the addictive stuff vicodin and xanax
any of the opiates oxy you say that we'd
would replace those we'd can help no
listen if you if you are need heavy
painkillers weed is not your thing
tylenol for CBD and and indicas which
will help with the pain relief that's
what I take man that's why I started
smoking a lot to begin with it's for my
back pain ah I feel like I've been doing
research about this and I'm starting to
feel like CBD is snake oil and if you
don't have if you don't you you gotta
have some weed in there it's staring no
THC in there you might just use that to
make your eggs here's what I the way
I've been described to me is that you
have to take you have everybody has an
empty tank you have to take enough CBD
to fill up your tank as soon as you fill
up your tank it works every time you
take it but when you don't have a full
tank if you just take it once it's not
Tylenol if you take a right it's not
solid it's not gonna make you feel
better just CBD just CBD but if the tank
fills up that's when it's effective
that's why it was explained to me like
so my wife was taking it to help her
relax with anxiety and the first two or
three times it didn't work then she
finally took it a fourth night in a row
and she was like I feel great just
relaxed but I I slipped her a little th
say to she she she went to one time she
can't take it she took an edible and she
threw up and she thought it was her
teeth and she goes my teeth and I'm an
[ __ ]
so I was like of course you are yeah I
was like maybe your d yeah yeah those
are your teeth she lost her mind doesn't
go not your teeth but she was already
too far down the rabbit hole
all right cool that's all right that's
okay we interested okay that's that one
topic I wanted to ask this guy about
yeah and I'm a big fan of mushrooms too
oh I don't know if I would even try
mushrooms I take mushrooms every Monday
night people ask me about that all honey
there's so much fun you know people say
to me all the time they always go like
mad love to see you on mushrooms so I'd
love to see you like really high you
know people say that about me yeah in a
controlled environment here we go guys
maybe one maybe one day I'll do a solo
episode and I'll just like [ __ ] get
every Monday night at least I do a show
from my backyard right called the high
life where I smoke weed and I turn on my
camera and I just go live for an hour
straight and I go from somebody who's
sober to somebody who should not be in
public during that hour but it's the
most fun I have every week all right
well maybe one day I'll come and be a
guest come on man I just don't like
smoking I don't like that carcinogen I
will figure it out for you yeah if it's
like cuz I when I had like a real bad
situation with a family member was the
first time like yeah I was with someone
who smokes weed weed they had like a
full-on weed pen yeah get your weed I
was like give me that you know but I
didn't I was so upset and everything
that I don't even know if I let it let
it help me yeah you know that's a big
thing too if your brain is like this
anyway yeah that's what I'm saying so I
had to like get to the point where that
comes in when I was in the car that time
and I was like revisited music yeah and
it was like I was just you know what
here's the thing though I didn't it was
happening like I was outside of my body
because I was thinking like I was like
you know you're like man this doesn't do
[ __ ] people always say it's just a
second I'm just driving and all of a
sudden I was just kind of like you know
and I was like oh [ __ ] yeah you know how
I can tell the weeds working sometimes
when I when I'm listening to music that
it wouldn't normally like and then
you're like I'm not even high but then
you're like oh [ __ ] is this panic at the
disco last one and I've wanted to talk
about this with someone else for so long
and so I thought when I saw you on no
calendar I was like god this is the guy
I'm gonna put a scenario for you all
right let's say you're the US District
Attorney today or whatever right and
Jeffery Epstein's people come to you
mm-hmm
and they say look we want immunity all
right or two years federal prison
she and I'll even pay I'll have a fund
for my victims and I'll give you 500 of
the most powerful men in the world who
have I facilitated young girls for would
you have taken that deal not with
immunity but that's the deal yeah that's
the deal no no you don't get to the good
that's what I'm saying like that's do
you know as I say you know I would you
know why I would ask why they killed him
yes you know why I would that's what
he's dead yes I would because immunity I
would keep an eye on that dude forever
but that's the thing right like that
could have been part of it but then you
you're taking 500 and these [ __ ] off
the street as opposed to one I take the
500 I think that that's what happened
man I think that they were in the
process of being like yellow
he has like I got a black book I'll give
you even if he said like son I'll give
you 10 names that'll blow your mind
yep and I just feel like those dudes got
on the phone on a conference call and
they were like yeah he's got to go and
they said well you want us to make it
look like an accident
listen I don't care if you burn the
building down yeah he's got to go yeah
there was a fire at the prison in one
cell
[Laughter]
no you know what some a friend of mine
who works in one of these intelligence
agencies you know what he told me a long
time ago if if everyone can get got and
I was like nah he was no no he said I
just want to let you know everyone can
get got and I was like because he's a
guy he was to come around sometimes I
don't want to say who I was traveling
with because then I'll give it away who
it was but it guy who's come around when
I must traveling with this person and
and he and we talking I was like what
but if this happened he was like listen
I'm telling you right now on high levels
it doesn't matter who you are if you're
if there's somebody above you more
powerful you can get got yeah and there
will people who will be able to get rid
of you without a trace it's a great
example of how crazy just having money
though is not enough no because there's
always other people with money actually
power and influence Trump money for sure
but a lot of times that is together
right I understand what I'm saying is
like not let's see not all on the same
level now because if you know there are
there dude you know what I mean it's not
on the same like just like just have him
like oh I have this amount of money I
could do whatever I want I think that's
the situation that guy was in I think he
thought he was untouchable based off
like you know he's like we're all in
this together
look I'm dude you're all right you're
doing bad I'm doing bad so I know you
know we know we can bring each other
down so let's not and then but the
moment that he got that's right
as soon as because you know it took back
to those other people he's about to turn
yeah oh yeah no no he's gonna die he
didn't even probably didn't even say it
like that it was just kind of like you
know you don't I mean you know press 1
on your because they weren't on a
regular phone if I've been on dial-up
like with a would roll buttons press to
8 if you want him to get press 2 if you
you know what but it's so crazy because
if I just told you in a movie
hey so listen in this scene the most
high-profile prisoner in the United
States the cameras are gonna go off in
front of his cell it's just it's you'd
read it and go man that's just not
that's not possible bro yeah yeah it
does
seem realistic you know and everyone's
gonna believe it everyone's gonna be
okay with the cameras yeah you're just
in no guards no guards no cameras it's
fine it's just it's making like movies
that we've seen like we look back and be
like oh maybe that was true if you want
to script that like a if you wrote the
script that like a reality TV show host
would become president of the United
States do you wouldn't believe that
either is called idiocracy you know I
mean you wouldn't believe it either so
it's like it's so weird but I know he's
like what you're saying like all of the
things that that about the epstein
situation you just go how is this okay
dude if I'm not even talking about the
[ __ ] anymore dude it's like it's that's
the crazy thing it's like nobody even
cares so there's there's rich people
someplace then one like this yeah good
job good job guys we got rid of that guy
let's make sure that that kind of [ __ ]
doesn't happen again you know we got rid
of that guy but let's watch the tape
yeah you know they got a tape no but
here's the thing funny but I know for
sure no you know what that you know what
that's you know what you know here's the
best part about it too for the
Illuminati people they whoever's in
charge there
they said they probably turned around
and said let's just be a lesson to the
rest you [ __ ] nobody is above
this - did you there's actually more law
and order in that guru yes
did you ever see Untouchables you know
that scene where he hits to do with the
team and he's walking around the table
and he's talking about team and how and
he hits that dude bashes that dude's
brain in with the bat that's that scene
oh hell you just hey everybody look
movie there's some you talk yeah yeah
this is what happens and I'm doing this
in front of all of you so you know
nobody's above getting a baseball bat to
the [ __ ] head and that's what
happened to holy God fathers totally
like you say I didn't know it was yeah
listen to Fredo can die everybody yeah
everybody can go everybody spread he
killed his brother that was just some
Illuminati justice yeah man so they said
hey guys you know this was lazy I know
you guys got horrible you know these
people that think they can do whatever
they want with anyone that they want
even they have some kind of like justice
yeah it's crazy to me though to hear
people like I saw one sign that said
justice for abstain I'm like that's
that's too far
this isn't about justice for Jeffrey
Epstein um I hope he got raped before he
got home do you know what I mean like
I'm not talking about justice for this
dude but I I but by the way though let
me not to cut you all but just to add on
to us you could use you could hear my
point they continue what you're saying
though is I I am a believer that
everybody deserves a fair trial even if
it's a Mickey Mouse trial yeah cuz you
know what it's not for them it's for the
people that don't do crime yes okay it's
for their victims - I get it Hitler
needs to be on trial yeah even if it's
gonna be a he's guilty
kangaroo court but he needs to be on
trial for the other people and now I
agree with that
like I agree that that's for the victims
but I also don't feel bad for this dude
yeah I totally agree it's not about
feeling bad it's just to support our
justice system like you know it's cuz
even someone like that if someone like
that can get a lawyer and and get a fair
trial
then the pretend oh you know then Joe
Schmo you know I mean but unfortunately
we live in a system right now that it's
like only the people that have money
gets their trial that's it or the best
work done there's no doubt like to me
the maybe the criminal justice system is
racist but to me it's more about money
you got money
you're gonna hell if you don't have if
it's a hundred percent uh Oh Jay was
just like hey so it doesn't matter if
I'm black I got a lot of money and I'm
just gonna keep riding this and they
just hammered it but didn't help Cosby
but but he's an example of somebody that
he got his trial yes you know I don't
you just want to see a day in the life
of Bill Cosby in jail if you if there
was a reality show and you like
twenty-four hours of Cosby in jail I
would tune in yeah that but it's like
that thing you can't say that without
being like it of course the proceeds go
to all those victims just watch it I
want to see what
to him it was a report that he's like
they love him and he's doing great in
there get everybody's jello
I don't know it's like they gotta love
it they grew up on him I you know I
don't know what jails really like know
when you watch something you watch like
lockup or one of those type of shows my
brother was in jail for a while not I
think six months and it's exactly what
he said he said you have no idea what
it's like no matter what you've seen
right what you have no idea what it's
like there was one time out recently I
was just in court supporting somebody
and I was I said to him my brother I was
talking about yeah they kept bringing
people out from a back before they get
to this person and then he said yeah
there's a cell underneath the the courts
that where were they hold people and he
goes and you know what not down there I
said what he said cameras I said what do
you mean he goes oh [ __ ] goes down in
the jail underneath the court he was
telling me about he was like was one
dude walked up to me and said cuz he had
just gotten these new shoes right he
said hey the man let me get those shoes
and my brother was like if I say no and
he was a spy Hispanic guy it's just even
if the other Hispanic guys in the jail
don't know him yeah it's them against me
right
but if I say yes they're taking [ __ ]
from me every [ __ ] day every [ __ ]
day and he said he's like hey he said I
I said no man you can't have my shoes
and the guy was like I'm gonna need I
need you to give me those shoes and so
my brother was sitting there like oh man
there we go yeah because if they do jump
me they're getting the shoes but they
know they have to fight anyway anyway
did they get the shoes they got the
shoes
[Laughter]
but it's a lose-lose situation I wanna
see your brother now be like yo bro
wassup
[Laughter]
every time you have him on your show it
Puma says he said to me I said Tim of
the story is he said well the guy he
didn't even get violent with me what he
said to me was he said listen man
they've got me he said they want me to
roll on this guy and I'm not rolling he
said look at the shoes they got me in
they were too small they had holes and
he said they're just worse he said
they're just tort they're just putting
bad [ __ ] I mean I'm in holding I mean I
said you know I said yeah what he call
it an isolation but uh solitary he said
they're just [ __ ] with me he said I
just need let me get those shoes man to
just make my day better so my brother
was like and heat my brother thought he
was going home and he was like yeah this
is my last day and my gift so when he
said he when he went back to jail he
told this old dude who'd had been in
jail a bunch she was telling the whole
story and he said so I gave the shoes
like he said he was like man he was like
I got he got he got listen we keep
talking forever and I don't want to do
that I really appreciate you coming on
the podcast have me man I'll have like
all your information down below so guys
please subscribe follow share get to
notifications whatnot
he's you got a great podcast going on
right now - you're not blowing up right
Facebook's great for you right now man
in that controlled chaos show I do for
old chaos we've changed it up a little
bit since the last time you were on it's
still the same amount of fun but it's
set more in a game setting
oh no but it's sponsored by Puma ever
gets it everybody's yeah I got some
great shoes I've gotten from from
I wear them all the time I got some
great transformer ones yeah man those
been hot yeah those are the best but
every Tuesday night live if you want to
see it live on my Facebook fan page and
then it gets put on my YouTube page I
just went over a million subscribers on
YouTube and so my comedy on there is
just pop it o mess you just call you
just Casilla you look like you got money
people say you know free things I wear
yeah a fan sent this you know the fan
sent the this stuff right here isn't it
crazy lot of great stuff isn't it crazy
he's coming to use bad money in peril
they send me [ __ ] you have money but
it's still free stuff it just feels good
it does appreciate ya that's your love
language don't like to get on that but
anyway guys this is Josh wolf and thanks
for watching riffing with Griffin and I
will see you next week
[Music]